welcome to this video playing our seed
or off we add I would have thought I
played them before but no statistic wow
the Albin's countering image don't see
that too often yeah a three is a decent
line against that and never looked at it
in in enough detail to really hope to
review this play button I think this is
one of the lines that gives right a
little something yeah White has the
somewhat better chances there on the
queenside okay so how am I playing this
92 yeah let's let's just be quick
they're not think too long might castle
long and King c3
oops I absolutely didn't look at this
born Wow okay that's how you win with
the album's counter gambit why does
blundering stuff on the queenside ah
what a howler okay i can maybe castle
long here I'm threatening Bishop b2
threatening this yes this is also
possible
we should be two castles long and that's
it
Jim
okay I'm not getting this night trap
down if I move my D tonight he will give
a play Knight to c4 or something to see
form I wouldn't have if taking as an
idea I don't know kind of frustrated
that i have blundering a3 is really a
bad idea especially against this opening
yeah it's really a good way to lose
their just blunder the apron I have to
play maybe a for whatever just not give
a three away and still not so easy to
get this get this piece is coordinated
fam there at least it seems that way I
have sometimes chances to escape two
opposite colored bishops or things like
that my ideas look the one and then
maybe queen bee to a king between okay
just a ticking just attacking be 5 D 6 C
5 possibly yes
simply not good not good disposition be
65 especially especially annoying I go
back take sexy has this discoveries
I don't know I have to play more I can
take with the bishop even Wow can just
get Bishop takes for the pin even night
x is good i'm going to just plain badly
at the moment here Bishop takes this is
the best I think just going into this
pin
don't have any any decent move against
that night a three Bishop b2 is just
busted yeah that that's also also good
problem I can't ads it's it's it's bad
anyway so I might as well just grab some
pond out okay maybe that is not that bad
night a five no place an ambitious move
okay
I know I can take the exchange but this
is check also possible okay I didn't see
that move of course as usual I don't see
anything in this game should be eight
and what is this Bishop a five-piece uf6
is equal material all of a sudden how
did that happen how did that happen
Bishop they're limiting is king okay
maybe Luke g6 group g6 of course yes
okay maybe he doesn't have a good
discovery yeah Bishop c6 was ridiculous
it's not that bad for me all of a sudden
bishop i don't know i don't know if i
should play that not clear to me but my
king might be useful there blocking the
pawns I can do I can do that check time
warning the shopping bag Bishop f4
Bishop C toon
he's stepping up with his King playing
so badly it's a shame it's just a shame
he completely let me beg back in the
game and then i'm giving it away again
yum in the end game check check okay
maybe even check maybe it's a draw at
least which actually is a draw check
check check check check check check ha I
came at least it's a draw out of mine
mmm I was lost from the opening so it's
okay but I welcome this wasn't is
starting to get better for white I mean
somewhere around here don't it should
have chances to pick up those pawns but
I'm just playing really really badly at
the moment so maybe here first this is
better for Bishop g5 txt for maybe check
yeah I really I really managed to make
it this is just bad yeah I just so bad
if I don't trade trade the bishops he's
not getting anywhere how should i do
this actually maybe start with that move
lookie here I can even a text stuff and
I have king d foil that's much better
i'm activating the king i have chances
to win one of the pawns and i must win
one of the pawns otherwise it's not
going to be any good in the game i was
worse again with with against those
pawns somehow i managed to get a draw
but damn that was a bad game yeah i
actually made a mistake there III is the
theoretical move him now i remember this
is better there should be six bishop t
for something like that and why does a
bit better this is leading to 22 that
much and well 92 is just just just sick
yeah gifting him the three Pawn it's
really really awful against such a well
the Aldens is just a bad opening so you
shouldn't shouldn't be worse really and
well this is kind of bad yeah after 13
moves in the Alvin's count again but
have this have this bad position okay
you cannot refute the opening at that
said that you have to have to say but
it's not really good this is a
relatively best line against this a
three set up and down yeah I forgot this
really our Bishop takes I can also do
this this this is an e3 and this is
always a bit better for white because of
the structure with the c7 corn being
weak right has an extra point in the
center there so it's comfortable for
white I should not give away a three
definitely not okay well thanks for
watching